always love having this guy on here on
the program and we are all I'll speak on
behalf of everyone at the NFL Network
and NFL Total Access and NFL players
only and total acess end game every
Thursday night football game after the
TNF postgame show speak and I never have
everyone thrilled that DeMarcus Ware is
part of our world up there at the NFL
Network in the NFL media group and
thrilled to have you here on the show
good to see also a good thing you got it
let's get right into it what has
happened to the Broncos all of a sudden
you know I mean I I always look at it
especially when I played what type of
strategy we had you know going into
their first two games they ran the ball
will with CJ Anderson they protect it
you know cherish him you don't turn the
ball over they've been turning the ball
over what almost two or three times a
game getting sacked four and five times
not protecting you know Simeon and then
the defense they're getting pressure
they're stopping a run but when you talk
about a key to leave when you talk about
Vaughn and Wolfe where the turnovers
what where the Turner was like there
used to get week in and week out like
for the first and second week that's not
there so they got to get back to their
strategy well I mean it it stunned me
that they're coming off a bye right the
Giants are winless they're without every
single one of their receivers who they
lost in succession almost one per
quarter the week before right that they
come in and they push to Denver around
and do you think that the Broncos came
off the bye already just putting that in
the win column I think I think when you
come off the bye week those are one of
those weeks of where you like okay
everybody's rested you come off the bye
week and we're playing against the
Giants they're giving up let's say 20
SEC's the game being funny but they're
giving up a lot of sacks a game so
talking from a pass rusher standpoint
we're gonna be the good pressure guess
what the Denver Broncos didn't we're
gonna be to run the ball all over the
defense because they're not playing well
but they didn't does that show that you
come off my week it happens okay
sometimes you can get complacent in the
mentality that you have oh I got this
game in the bag no every game every week
is a new game and you have to look at it
that way so in my four down segments
that I've been doing
every single week I'm gonna do it
Brockman you didn't think I was gonna do
it but I'll do it here okay so I give
three takes throw three downs and then
on fourth down regardless of down and
distance I go for it okay I hot take it
okay okay all right so last week I said
the Cowboys are missing the playoffs
okay okay this week I said the Broncos
may not win another game the rest of the
season okay that's number two those are
the ad that's all I got Bayless is
embarrassed for me I mean so the Broncos
you look at their next three games or at
Kansas City at Philadelphia home for New
England and I look at when I think about
those games though the big games yes
injuries Emmanuel Sanders you got
Demaryius Thomas but the thing is they
still can win games if they get back to
their strategy you got a hand the ball
to CJ Anderson I don't care what you say
you better get that run game going
because when you go up there and at high
altitude and you play the Denver Broncos
by the second half you're tired because
we've ran the ball down your throat and
that's what we do and on defense we've
played all year up here in the snow or
in the high altitudes so we use it
against you so what are you gonna do are
you gonna get back to your strategy are
you gonna mope around that's what I feel
about the situation they can win they
can win those games
you said a probably will make the
playoffs or win another game they can do
it no I'm not saying that if
biconditional first they may not win
another game maokai like they were may
okay that's the way I kind of couched it
if I really wanted a hot take is they
won't they won't win another game but of
course I'm not gonna say that when
they've got Cincinnati and the Jets the
Jets are visiting on December right I
mean it could start snowing or you know
and then then they do actually okay I
have to DeMarcus Ware here in the Rich
Eisen show what do we take out of the
Cowboys win then against San Francisco
what do you take out of that same thing
again they're coming off football week
they lost two games right and the
questions coming into the season can dak
and Zeke play the offensive line are
they gonna be just as good
losing their right tackle and their left
guard and their young defense can they
actually play you know what the last
three games that Ezekiel you can see
they're running the ball very well the
offensive line is blocking sort of
control in the trenches and they just
got back shortly and then they were
worried about
Jaylon Smith can he play because with
the wit Hitchens both of those guys hurt
he came in and start playing well and so
now you can see they're starting to get
their identity back especially from the
bottle we can say hey we can be a
contender in the NFC East and play well
because you did think about DeMarcus
marzo ain't know where he came from how
many sexy ever enough well I mean he had
that game in Arizona that he kind of
single-handedly won that game in yeah
there was a touchdown taken off the
board because he drew a holding penalty
on it just on a three-man rush what was
it he was an animal and now you got
David Irving back you know Tyrone
Crawford those guys and taco he just
needs to bring it along to do what he
needs to do and I feel like they can win
games from there but from that game my
take from that game they've got their
identity in they can win games if they
stay on the right path yeah I mean
they're there first of two against the
Redskins who were three and three I mean
that is a big huge guy at the Eagles
yeah and as I mentioned sitting there at
six and one the Cowboys right now are
ninth in the conference and they're not
they're not gonna win this division
well the question is there's a path to
the playoffs they've got to be better
than either the Seahawks of the Rams and
they've already lost to the Rams right
they've got to be better than the
Packers or the Panthers they've already
lost to the Packers but the Packers
don't have an iron Roger and then who
knows what happens with the Lions were
sitting right there at 3 and 3 it's you
don't you don't know and it's a hard
door to open up and the thing is they
can't make any mistakes during this
season because you see what you're up
against you shot Philly there's probably
r1 the NFC's right would you get across
I mean they they're playing well enough
to win games even though you know Jason
Peters and you know Jordan Hicks they
got hurt but they still have a good team
that can still win
and what you
talk about the game last night it was
big look how well they played even
though those guys came out of the game
they played will well went to me you
know wench to me is what I mean who is
this time well I mean you could see that
he's getting better with each week right
when he makes a mistake he doesn't make
it again know that he's just he's like
adapting like he's like this being that
is an adaptive being that is slot
machine eventually if you keep pressing
in mr. Jack pop then suddenly it's no
longer just cherries right no but so so
I think he is that good
but then there's Brady sitting there and
the a any who do you think is the best
team in the AFC threw seven weeks to
Marcus were the best team in the AFC I
would say the Patriots I still think
about do you think about the Kansas City
Chiefs how well they're playing but can
they play well like that the whole
season the rest of the season and now
you think about the Patriots they're
coming in you know Brady's been playing
lost our MVP elite status been doing we
needs to do but then the defense
struggled at the beginning of a season
and all of a sudden now Matt Patricia
comes in and he says can we play well
can we have a turnaround this for
championship teams but that's what they
do and you can see the last two or three
games they're starting to play where
they're starting to get their identity
they're starting to buy in buy into you
know what we're still that championship
caliber team and you can see when you
know the Patriots you know they play
Kansas City they can win games mm-hmm so
I feel like that's still the team to
beat if they play that type of mentality
what about the Steelers what do you
think about I mean yeah same same thing
just on the flipside the offices in
start will with the killaby but
brownbill and not being Roethlisberger
you know what Tomlin comes in and he
says hey what I'm gonna put my finger on
you guys and make sure that we give the
ball to bill that's going to move the
chains take the pressure off of being
and give it to my playmaker Brown and
you can see now that there
all finns have had a big turn around and
there's still curtin defense is playing
now that they're playing and now you're
also seeing DeMarcus Ware here on the
Rich Eisen show you're also seeing that
part of the season now where the cracks
in the armor become public you're
hearing some members of the Buccaneers
like TJ Ward right say that I didn't
come here to be a backup right then you
see T Walton for 2 & 5 Indianapolis
start to say the offensive line needs to
account for itself what happens in a
locker room where the losing begins to
creep in and the season begins to get
you know late fast I think it's all
about the mentality that you take if you
are going into a losing season you can
go in and say you know this right here
is what we have and I want to spoil the
game for each one of these teams even
though I'm not gonna make it because I'm
playing for it the guy beside me cuz we
worked our butts off this whole
offseason in during the season right now
to get where we are or you can be that
bad apple and say you know I'm not
getting the ball
we're not playing well there's always a
way to point the finger at somebody else
but why don't you point at yourself
well martavis Bryant right now for five
and to Pittsburgh is saying that that he
needs to get the ball more or he's not
gonna stand for his role in the offense
anymore if you're in that locker room
with somebody saying okay alright walk
me through it if you if you sit right
here
I'm just saying using it as an example
with Tyree keel some games he's a decoy
he doesn't get the ball but Kareem hunt
Alex Miller they ball out it's a team
sport but if that happens in the locker
room and I get a guy and that comes in
and say I'm not getting the ball I would
ask him are you open are you open
are you are you a team player I mean
being a captain and I will grind him in
his face and let him know that this team
is bigger than you because you are just
a player and if you can't be on this
team and you want to be an individual
get out of the locker room I'll look at
him strength
they say get out of locker room if you
were in Pittsburgh right now if I was in
Pittsburgh right now get it out of
locker room and guess what I'll have the
whole team behind my back because I
worked my butt off
we worked our butts off to get to this
point yes and if you don't want to be
part of this get out okay who you are
and then I'll see you on Facebook live
because Antonio Brown is putting that on
lot of social media
that's fine I'll watch it live let's
take a break I want to take a quick
break
discuss what you're doing tomorrow okay
in your personal life I want to hit on
that because you're beginning to do some
singing career oh yeah I want to hit
that and then also back on the football
field what you think is happening in a
Seattle locker room where yes they are
winning but the offense and the defense
are definitely on different levels of
success or efficiency right now right I
want to hit that next with DeMarcus Ware
Method Man waiting in the wings that's
how we're rolling here on this very busy
Tuesday edition of the Rich Eisen show
all right a couple minutes while the
radio audience goes away DeMarcus Ware
here you know we were talking about on
the on the network a few weeks ago when
about the game where Aaron Rodgers came
in for the injured Favre in Dallas on a
Thursday night in the old Texas Stadium
and we were there as a network because I
think you guys were undefeated and Favre
had only one loss or vice-versa
hmm okay and it was Romo versus far
every ball mo grew up with Fox poster on
a wall and five got hurt right and
Rodgers came in and I remember we were
all sitting there going oh wait a minute
were you like that on the field too
where did you get a jesting - I think I
got hurt that game as well I remember
that but it was one of those things
where you're thinking like I mean it's
Romo gonna be that guy but then I
practice against him all the time and he
crushes us okay and this one the birth
of Romo happened that was a big game
then oh yeah I remember that
that was a big game but I remember Aaron
Rodgers coming in and we were all like
huh this guy can play too and we were
given much grief like all your boy Favre
look look over his shoulder
yeah but but the thing is
you can see that that happens weekend
and week out you can see where Romo
there's Dan with you know when Bledsoe
was in the game it was Romo
all right that's right there was Bledsoe
in with the Patriots there was Brady
yeah so it happens in the league and do
you think Romo got a call from the
Packers I think he got a call from the
Packers yeah I think I think he do you
know if he got a call I don't know if he
got a call from the Packers but I know
look at teams they they do call and
still want you to do something yeah I
mean okay
I still get call oh you just today even
to this very day yeah it calls it it's
very day
DeMarcus can we rush the passer no I'm
done I'm done but people still want to
know they still want to know I'm telling
you everybody gets cause if so Romo got
a call you got a call that makes sense
from your Hall of Fame got a phone call
Oh somebody call you nobody's coming Oh
[Laughter]
DeMarcus Ware here on the show before we
hit the two subjects that we want to hit
that I teased you mentioned in the
television only segment when I asked if
you thought Romo got a call for the
Packers he said he thought he did then
you started smiling saying that you got
a phone call yeah you've gotten a phone
call this morning
today today like 15 minutes hero before
you walked in here yeah asking if you
want to return to the NFL NFL this is
the time that where teams want pass
rushers and pass rushers you know they
get hurt during the season let me just
walk through this real quick okay cuz I
know you're not gonna tell me which team
it is okay even if it runs with Shem
Enver or Shem Alice does this team
assume you would say yes and thus you'd
be on the field this coming Sunday yes
I'm sure you would assume yes they would
assume me being
ready for this game Sunday the roaster
passer you know at least 15 times in
game so the hope was they call you
DeMarcus Ware on your phone and you know
you know what I've enjoyed the NFL
Network thing and I know that that will
be there when I'm done but I do miss the
game so much yes I will play for you
this Sunday for X amount of dollars for
the rest that was their hope that's
exactly their hope but you know what I
will do whatever I can to help the team
you know not myself I'm not getting out
there and I'm not playing anymore I'm
done but whatever I can do to help the
team I'm there 100%
so Freedy must have gotten to call this
season too don't you think you know
three I would imagine you know fringo
and he's said no I don't know if he said
no or not maybe he's working through
contractual things I don't know he might
come weeked in like week ten but did you
think about it for a second where I got
thought about it I thought about right
putting the pants back on it really
smashing some guy's head be honest with
you I'm being honest with you right now
but I changed my mind I went back into
my Zen the Bruce Banner mode not
Incredible Hulk yes and put my glasses
on and say you know what no I'm gonna
talk about you know football and just
enjoy life how long did it take for you
to get the Bruce Banner back on who's
better
yeah yeah Bruce Banner how I mean if you
wanted to put on like a quarterback
jersey right now and one of you one of
you guys snap the ball and I can
actually like turn to my brothers I
don't know
green all right now see you think I'm
playing for the Eagles I'm not very
wench like wow okay
DeMarcus we're here on the Rich Eisen
show the Seahawks defense ballin out the
offense seems to constantly be three and
outing them back on the field in
situations where they have to keep it
one possession game all the time yes for
the for the either the operands to come
back or keep it right where it is
so the offense already up one possession
can add to it what's happening in that
locker room do you think from a
defensive standpoint the offense almost
have to give the defense a little bit of
credit don't go nonchalantly not
recognizing what we're doing if the
offense comes to the defense and say hey
I know we're not playing well we're not
gonna lose the game for you're not going
to turn the ball over
we're gonna control the clock and we're
gonna wait for you guys to get turnovers
we're gonna wait for you guys that get
interceptions make big plays give us a
short field and we're gonna score points
that's the strategy we need to have for
the rest of the season cuz you know that
we have a better offensive line that's
not you know protecting me right now I'm
talking from a Wilson standpoint uh-huh
right we I know we're not running the
ball as effective and we're keeping you
guys on the field the whole time I thank
you for that but this is what we need to
do to win games instead of it being a
seperated thing to where it's an offense
and defense deal to where you know what
offers not playing well we got to pick
up the pieces not it's still team sport
let's come together let's figure this
out we know what we're not good at in
Listia win game last minute a half for
your left who you hang with again
tomorrow
ooh am i hanging with yeah we hang with
tomorrow drop snoop snoop dogg tomorrow
yeah you're singing with him singing
with him yes what what's the deal with
the with the NFL it's called superheroes
and what it what it is is to raise
awareness for with my with my daughter
situation it's with a DD right it's a
big epidemic around and you know my kids
actually gonna be on there too so it's
gonna be fun and it's a good way to just
raise awareness and and just make things
that make the world a better place man
with all the stuff going on so how you
so you can rap you know I'm not rapping
at all I might sing a little bit I know
what you're trying to do you're trying
to get me at least sing a note or
something on the stage right now no I'm
not yes you are I feel it I'm feeling I
feel like boiling rock I feel like you
want to know I'm know I don't but uh and
I'm not rapping so we're good I I feel
like you'd really like to swear here on
the Rich Eisen show mere seconds after
telling the Dallas Cowboys thanks but no
thanks
no he's trying his best to try to get
Speaker I was
and here in our number three on the Rich
Eisen show for more Rich Eisen show
tuned - audience Channel 239 on Direct
TV or download the Rich Eisen show app